- Beschreiben Sie sich mit eigenen Worten,
um die Partnersuche zu erleichtern. Ja.
Mein Name ist … Milan.
Ich bin 75 Jahre alt,
aber trotzdem noch sehr aktiv.
Ich bin für alles offen.
Ich bin ein
humorvoller, loyaler Mann
und suche eine sportliche,
charmante Frau …
- Jacques?
- Inge!
- Warst du bei der Bank?
- Ja, ich war bei der Bank.
- Und?
- Es gibt da immer noch
irgendein Problem …
- Hast du …?
- Ja, ich habe alle wichtigen
Formulare ausgefüllt,
trotzdem schaffen sie es nicht,
meine Überweisung zu bearbeiten.
Ich verstehe das wirklich nicht!
- Aber du musst doch die Übernachtung
und die Fahrt heute noch bezahlen.
- Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Es tut mir leid, Inge.
Das ist so peinlich.
Erst lade ich dich ein und …
und dann passiert so was.
Aber wenn die Bank das Problem
nicht lösen kann, müssen wir stornieren.
- Auf keinen Fall!
Du hast vielleicht Probleme mit deiner Bank,
trotzdem fahren wir ein paar Tage weg.
Ja, ich kann die Reise doch bezahlen.
Das ist kein Problem!
- Auf keinen Fall!
- Jacques …
Du bist kein Fremder aus dem Internet.
Ich habe dich nicht in irgendeinem
Partnerportal kennengelernt.
Ich kenne dich lange genug.
Ich vertraue dir.
- Natürlich …
- Also!
Ich bezahle die Reise.
Keine Diskussionen.
Wenn du unbedingt willst,
kannst du mir das Geld zurückgeben,
wenn du die Probleme mit
der Bank gelöst hast. Einverstanden?
- Einverstanden.